I believe today's meeting does Mark A
New Beginning
and on taunt renewed we are looking to
the Future a future that builds on all
that we share our history our geography
our values
and a future that is far more ambitious
about how we work together to improve
the lives of the people that we serve
we've discussed every aspect of our
crucial Alliance today and made an
important progress in three areas in
particular illegal migration energy and
security
Emmanuel and I share the same belief
criminal gangs should not get to decide
who comes to our countries within weeks
of my coming into office we agreed our
largest ever small boat steel and today
we've taken our cooperation to an
unprecedented level to tackle this
shared challenge
we're announcing a new Detention Center
in northern France a new Command Center
bringing our enforcement teams together
in one place for the first time and an
extra 500 new officers patrolling French
beaches all underpinned by more drones
and other surveillance technologies that
will help ramp up the interception rate
and the legislation the UK has
introduced this week supports this
because it's designed to break the
business model of the criminal gangs and
remove the pull factors bringing them to
the channel Coast
now we will always comply with our
International treaty obligations but I
am convinced that within them that we
can do what is necessary to solve this
shared problem and stop the boats
second the UK and France are working
together so that never again can the
likes of Putin weaponize our energy
security
you are helping us to secure our supply
of nuclear power thanks to EDS
incredible work at sideswell C and
through our ports and interconnectors we
can be Europe's Gateway for non-russian
gas but today we are going even further
with an ambitious new energy partnership
we've signed a new deal on civil nuclear
cooperation agreed that France will
examine the case for new energy
interconnectors and committed to work
together on low carbon energy together I
believe we are creating a future where
every watt of energy powering our homes
and Industry will come from secure
sustainable and reliable sources
third the UK and France share a special
bond
and a special responsibility
when the security of our continent is
threatened we will always be at the
Forefront of its defense
and today we're going even further to
strengthen our security and defense
cooperation
we've agreed to train Ukrainian Marines
helping to give Ukraine a decisive
advantage on the battlefield and for
Ukraine to win this war
to increase the interoperability of our
forces harnessing the full potential of
the combined joint expeditionary Force
to promote security and stability in the
indo-pacific coordinating our carrier
deployment and we will jointly explore
the development of complex weapons like
air defense combat air and long-range
weapons
now for decades we've been two of the
world's biggest defense powers and
leading contributors to Nato
and we will continue to stand together
for Freedom democracy and the rule of
law